if shine for roses and Rose a difficult
that's what you get when your buyer
champagne the drugstore okay guys so
today we are not doing Rose a we are
doing champagne playing it fast and
loose with the word champagne to
celebrate the second-to-last episode and
sandals ooh sweets whoo we got the
finish the grand finale and it was very
grand - rayvin fantasy suite one on one
and then we also got Rachel's and we
also got Vanessa's and we'll get into
them both right now I don't know why I'm
doing this whatever obviously I need to
work out any way that I can so Raven is
satisfied I'm really satisfied today
she's literally skipping and jumping and
high-fiving people and petting dogs I am
going to go ahead and guess that they
filmed this montage for the fantasy
suites and then I liked it in after but
I don't know maybe they didn't maybe
Mick really left Raven that I'm really
satisfied today and if you didn't next
please write a book write a book and
write down all your tips because all
straight men everywhere need these tips
and all straight women everywhere want
their men to have these tips and maybe
Nick style is the sex God that we've all
needed for so long give us the tips then
we move on to Rachel's date Rachel does
not know what cross-country skiing it I
have no idea what cross-country skiing
but I know it'll be fun that's the
optimism of this show you guys
someone can dive into an activity
they're completely unfamiliar with and
feel guaranteed to have sort of a good
time turn to that so Rach on Nick go
cross-country skiing and they need some
reindeer have you seen Santa and then we
get into their problems because we all
know regionals going to go home so we
got to see what allegedly goes wrong
because they seemed a pretty good
connection up to this point okay so
here's how it was justified one Rachel
says she can't talk I'm terrible at work
too just like very hard for me sometimes
to verbalize things it doesn't feel that
justified guys it just does not and
ultimately both of them to clear their
feelings that I'm falling in love with
you
rachel says she's falling in love Nick
says he's going for Rachel Rachel I am
falling for you greens are usually
imitative these people are at the I Love
You phase but still it was saying a lot
and then Rachel said is that which is
those the week I'm looking forward to
what's next after the rose because you
know I know that I'll get to meet his
family
and I'm it was me he's family slightly
the bummer is Rachel seems to really
think things are going well she's
talking like she's guaranteed to get a
rose like she's gonna meet Nick's family
over in Waukesha Wisconsin it's okay
babe stay in Finland okay and then we do
it or so we think
I don't know it's implied whatever okay
kit ooh time for a bun and then things
get icy between Nick and Vanessa both
literally and figuratively that's why
some fun yep
I wish I had some ice but then Who am I
kidding no I'm not going to stop
drinking it that's the thing it's like
this is a metaphor for these
relationships things are only going okay
and yet you keep forging ahead for
television so Nick and Vanessa like
plunge in and out of this ice bath drink
every time they get in or out of the ice
bath oh my god okay so now we got to
have some problems between Nick and
Vanessa because we've got to build the
drama here Nick and Vanessa's problems
first
Nick says he's very traditional yeah and
he is so no I'm not
traditional at all she says my core
values are things that I don't want to
compromise on she's not gonna give up
what on Sundays you have lunch my job
Vanessa love lunch and then they move to
the next location and more problems
arise like she is American I'm like
really proud to be an American and she
is Canadian and I'm very proud of it I'm
saying or not I know remember how he
said he didn't like how traditional she
was I'm just kidding he likes it he's my
no tradition I love that your family's
traditional okay I will point out that
I'm not like are they two different
you're not so different I think he's
similar you're right
what if they're two different what if
we're too similar what if they're too
I'm like what if they're too alike
this is so hard drink every time this is
hard
our conversations are always so heavy I
don't know
also now they sounded unhealthy I think
my relation with Vanessa has the
potential to have more conflict but also
this relationship has the best chance I
don't know what is it all come down to
the end Vanessa
unlike Rachel said I know I love you so
maybe that's just what makes the
difference is that these bachelors need
to really feel the emotions from the
person they're interested in
and when I say what makes the difference
maybe I mean what makes the similarity
because you're not for different who
knows anymore opposites attract
like repel American chameleon
no Jean hamburger maple syrup it's all
hard and then Vanessa cries and then
Nick bride they both like to cry that's
a similarity and I guess Ravens still
here somewhere she shows up at the rose
ceremony so at the rose ceremony one of
the first of the season I would argue
Nick only has two roses to give out one
to Raven ones have been
Rachel I'm just being dramatic because
that's what the shows about
okay so Rachel goes home and she leaves
in an ocean full of mascara tears and
god what a good way to go out on reality
television of course she's going to
return to the restaurant and we can not
wait you guys I've interviewed Rachel
twice now legitimately she is such a
great interview she's so smart and fun
and great to talk to check it all Avenue
Pam I'm calm I will never leave this
video without a plug is this making you
nervous let's go to spill so we also
after this hour-long episode had the
bachelor women tell all special but I'm
not getting into it because I don't have
enough champagne for that so you guys
can check out the women tell all
coverage a TV online comm where we have
23 things you didn't see on TV at the
bachelor women tell all
yes I was there for the taping I wrote
it all up very scintillating drink until
you're done reading all 23 bang you
don't read that fast nobody reads that
best read it so it's interesting
thank you guys so much for watching we
only have one episode left the season
finale of The Bachelor airs next Monday
on ABC
of course ET will be covering and you
can follow me on social media
to talk about The Bachelor more like ET
on Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube
and stay cool like the ice in Finland
and stay different like Nick from
Vanessa and stay similar to yourself be
true to you everybody have a great I am
a master's degree there was so many
times I think that it's some kind that
slike something for your
[Applause]